Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit, mal wieder nach Italien zu blicken auf die Serie A und da kann es nur einen Gast geben, hier im Rasenfunk. Christian Bernhard von DAZN unter anderem ist wieder hier, jetzt in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 137. Bernie, sei mir sehr herzlich willkommen hier in den Rasenfunk Headquarters.
Hallo Max, wunderschön, hier zu sein.
Ja, ich finde das toll, dass wir wieder über die Serie A sprechen. Mein Gott, uns beiden brannte es unter den Nägeln, das kann man hier an der Stelle mal verraten. Aber ich hatte noch so viele andere Ligen abzufrüstigen. Es ist ein Jammer. Aber jetzt endlich können wir über die Serie A sprechen. Und gibt es denn Themen?
Ich würde sagen, das eine oder andere gibt es, oder? Ich glaube, wir finden das eine oder andere.
Ich glaube, wir finden das eine oder andere. Ich habe unter anderem gelesen, um damit mal gleich zu beginnen, dass Gianluigi Buffon, der ja jetzt UN-Botschafter geworden ist, natürlich, warum auch nicht, hat auf der entsprechenden Veranstaltung gesagt, es gibt nur einen Fall, bei dem ich mir vorstellen könnte, mich auf die Bank zu setzen. Und das ist Juve. Das sind die schönen Geschichten, die nur der Fußball schreibt.
Jaja, klar, der war jetzt am Anfang. Gut, das ist halt so eine Nummer, die in Italien immer wieder vorkommt. Das neue Spiel, die gerade aus dem Ausland kommen, da sind die Trainer manchmal vielleicht übervorsichtig und wollen die nicht zu früh reinwerfen. Gerade bei Rebic aber ist das, finde ich, ein bisschen unverständlich, weil der gerade einer ist, der auch von der Bank kommt, da wirklich auch so einen Impuls setzen kann mit seiner Dynamik. Der ist auch einmal in Verona, wo Milan eines seiner wenigen Spiele gewonnen hat. Gut gemacht hat in der zweiten Halbzeit. Ja, also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das jetzt unter Piolli funktioniert. Ich würde es ihm wünschen, dass es ein sehr angenehmer Zeitgenosse ist, der auch mit der Fiorentina diese schwierige Phase mit Astoria mitgemacht hat, als ein sehr besonnener Trainer, der auch schon mal kurz bei Inter auf der Bank gesessen ist, also auch der ein bisschen diese Medienwelt in Mailand auch kennt.
Wobei er bei Inter ja auch nicht wirklich erfolgreich war.
Nein, aber da muss man auch dazu sagen, es war die Phase, wo bei Inter keiner erfolgreich war. Das sind ganz andere Trainer eben auch. Das war diese Post-Morino-Phase, wo einfach jeder, der kam, im Prinzip an den Ansprüchen und an den Dingen gescheitert ist. Und ja, ich wünsche ihnen jetzt einfach, dass sie da ein bisschen Ruhe reinkriegen und irgendwie dieses Verhältnis mit den Fans kippen. Weil ja, klar, Milan immer noch einer der großen Namen ist. Ich glaube, er ist einer der großen Traditionsfahnen. Ich glaube, darüber müssen wir nicht diskutieren.
Ach Mensch, die Serie A. Jetzt haben wir wieder nur über die üblich Verdächtigen gesprochen. Wir haben trotzdem schon unsere Stunde voll. Aber die anderen Vereine holen wir mal wann anders nach. Das hat wie immer großen Spaß gemacht, mit dir über die Serie A zu sprechen. Danke dir.
Ja, Max, mir auch.
Bist du sicher nicht irgendwann mal zu Twitter kommen aktuell? Einmal muss ich es noch fragen.
Du hast das schon recht. Ich möchte es nicht ausschließen.
Sehr gut. Das ist mehr, als ich erwarten konnte. Christian Bernhard von DAZN. Wann kann man dich das nächste Mal hören auf DAZN?
Am Wochenende darf ich die italienische Nationalmannschaft gegen Griechenland begleiten. Und in der Woche darauf Juve gegen Bologna.
Das ist jetzt nicht das schlechteste Programm. Also, hört dem Bernie auch auf DAZN zu. Es lohnt sich. Danke dir, dass du hier warst, Bernie.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, sehr schön, dass wir wieder über die Serie A sprechen konnten. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 137. Wenn ihr es noch nicht gehört habt, dann hört auch mal in unsere Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga rein. Und Tribüngespräche gibt es auch. Ein ganz brandfrisches zu den Football Leagues. Und ich verspreche euch, bald kommt schon das nächste. Oh ja. Ich freue mich. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis bald im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.